devant le lycée léopold sédar ils sont
un peu moins d'une centaine à avoir
bravé la pluie et le vent le sujet leur
tient à coeur ils ne veulent pas
l'implantation d'une prison à
magnanville l'association tous mobilisés
contre la prison a publié un manifeste
de 24 pages afin de démontrer que le
terrain est mal choisi déjà première
premiers éléments il ya nappes
phréatiques sur le terrain il n'a
phréatiques et des des sources vagabonde
qui alimente j'irai l'eau l'eau potable
du mantois ça veut dire que si on ramène
1200 personnes sur le terrain c'est à
dire 700 700 prisonniers plus 500 ans
500 travailleurs en risque de polluer le
terrain est pollué la nappe phréatique
autre point d'inquiétude le projet sera
construit sur une zone inondable avec la
bétonisation en cas de fortes pluies
l'association craint que le phénomène ne
s'aggrave mais ce qu appréhende
également les magnans villois c'est le
flux de véhicules que la prison va
engendrer pour cette commune de 6000
habitants on se pose de grosses
questions sur les mobilités puisque on
nous annonce un centre pénitentiaire de
près de 700 places avec à peu près
autant d'employés ça veut dire tous les
jours des salariés qui viennent sur leur
lieu de travail qui en repartent qui
vont traverser notre commune qui est
déjà un peu particulière puisque on a
une départementale qui coupent notre
village en deux et qui passe non loin de
d'école d'un collège en qu'on
s'interroge sur leflux que ça peut
représenter et la sécurité de nos
habitants et de nos enfants pour le
moment l'heure est au dialogue et à la
concertation les habitants et les
membres de l'association ont de l'espoir
nous quand on a appris sa fin fin
septembre début octobre
tout le monde était inquiet bon c'est
vrai que maintenant on a rencontré des
politiques on avance on on s'aperçoit
qu'ils aient un dialogue constructif
avec au démarrage ce n'était pas facile
la porte était fermée aujourd'hui les
portes s'ouvrent la future prison devra
contenir 700 places et voir le jour à
l'horizon 2027